welcome back to new rockstars this is
big question the show that gives you too
much information about the best way to
watch
an entire city get blown to smithereens
while people get the flesh
ripped from their bones like like wet
twilight oh
my god i guess really graphic mt and i'm
here today with the man the myth the
legend
eric voss how you doing today eric i'm
doing good mt are we doing our boom boom
episode we're
we're breaking booms we have breaking
boom
boom you looking for this
oh my god we go we gotta talk about a
lot of boobs a lot a whole lot of boobs
about to come
about to go down so get ready because in
the recently released
zack snyder film the army of the dead
one of the main plot points revolves
around a nuclear strike to kill
all of the zombie tourists hanging out
in las vegas now i for one love a big
nuclear explosion in a movie as much as
the next guy so that
got us thinking about this week's big
question what are some of the best and
worst uses of nuclear explosions
in cinema and how does the nuke in army
of the dead rank among them
we gotta be honest with our viewers and
t we've just been dying to do a nuke
episode of this
because i don't know about you i just
like going through youtube and being
like oh yeah there's a nuke in
this scene oh how do they make it look
there uh just
hollywood's take on um something that's
so
horrible and terrifying it's just kind
of fun to see
how wrong they get it
we're not nuclear experts um but we know
when something's a little over the top
or when something's just like too
triggering what we'd like to do is go
through
the most iconic nuke scenes in movies
and kind of rape it should people be
more worried about the radioactive
fallout afterwards
maybe get under a concrete structure or
something uh
or get as far away as they can what we
decided to do
is uh divide these up into kind of three
tiers
you know and and rank them based on
their
i guess you could say range of narrative
weight as um
in terms of how necessary are they for
the story
or are they really just spectacles and
first we have the bonkers and mostly
implausible uses of a nuke like
borderline unnecessary and used just for
spectacle and like and secondly
we have our realistic nukes designed to
evoke fear
and used as like a cautionary tale of
sorts and these are usually a bummer and
then finally we have the more cerebral
what have we done categories what have
we done what have we done
good god this is where the nukes are
just like a first step that create the
new horrifying world
that the characters have to deal with
and the goal isn't to bum out the
audience but to explore the scary sci-fi
consequences of that so got it let's put
on our radioactive suits
as we trudge into the blast zone and
rank these big ol
boom booms
all right mt thanks for laying that out
yeah we'll start with the bonkers so
this is the
these are the movies where it's just
ridiculous wildly inaccurate
pretty much pointless to the plot maybe
downright bad
uh and we'll start with the one that
kind of changed the game
for how we talk about movies indiana
jones and the kingdom of the crystal
skull
uh this is uh the movie that gave us the
origin of the phrase
nuke the fridge uh replacing jump the
shark essentially
but this is the movie that uh begins
around area 51 in nevada
in 1957. it's the same region where army
of the dead begins but goes in a very
different direction
and basically after having some high
jinks with uh cate blanchett
uh indy ends up in a nuclear test site
and uh goes into a lead-lined fridge
and is somehow able to survive a test
nuke and is able to look up at the
mushroom cloud um
and doesn't really seem to have any kind
of radiation poisoning afterwards
he seems totally fine he's just like hey
cool look at that radiation cloud that
i'm staring directly at
someone's saying he uh looks stronger as
that movie
what was in that news that he got super
power
no but yeah now actually this is kind of
based on real nuclear tests that were
happening
in the nevada desert at the time as part
of the military's operation
plum bomb but even though these sites
did exist
no way indy would survive that yeah
everything else in that makeshift town
is
completely wiped out but the fridge is
just kind of
punted you know it doesn't make sense
and it's even unlikely that the lead
lining in that bridge would be enough to
protect them like some
british undergrads were publishing a
report on this scene
in the journal of physics special topics
in 2016 they concluded quote
it is unlikely indiana would have
remained unharmed from the gamma
radiation
as the minimum thickness of lead needed
is
4.58 centimeters which is likely to be
greater than the thickness of the lead
lining within the bridge
the minimum thickness and everyone in
the uk is like
why are you doing this let's talk about
the minimum
thickness eric what's the minimum
thickness shut up
just stupid american your actually
sounds stupid to us
yeah and of course gave us the phrase
nuke in the fridge i think we can all
agree
[Music]
majorly bonkers and uh highly inaccurate
now i would also say the same for
uh movie i actually really love the dark
knight rises um
the third of the christopher nolan
batman movies which uh
brought in the uh nuclear bomb
into gotham city as a way of just to
have a ticking clock
a literal bomb like kind of the most
adam west
the christopher nolan went you know have
a bomb that batman has to dis um
i wish it was like a big old like
cartoon looking bomb with a few yes
so i gotta get this out of here it's a
nuke and you know
while the idea of you know a stolen nuke
or turning a reactor into a nuke i don't
know you can argue how
possible it is the craziest thing about
it is how does batman freaking survive
it
like he totes it out across the water
and
there must have been some kind of bat
submarine out there waiting for him
there's no way he could have just
dropped it and been far enough out of
the blast radius to survive it come on
eric he's batman he just dodged it he
was like whoops
got it tried to get me whoops
it's one of many logical leaps in that
movie that
at the end of the day i forgive because
i love so much what nolan did with that
trilogy but
of the three dark knight rises is the
hardest one to go back to
it might be because we have to root for
an army of police officers
beating up protesters it's just kind of
hard to reconcile that yeah going back
is kind of rough and the actual fight is
laughable because like it's just in the
background no one's hating anyone it's
just
it looks like comedy like go back and
watch that scene because the fight
like the background actors are just
hilarious to watch yeah oh and
even earlier then there's that
background actor who uh the stunt guy
who was just like
acting like batman was hitting him but
he's just like oh yeah
i just had quite a few oversights in
that one yeah christopher nolan uh this
is not not his strong suit i feel
um but he's a great director he's so
good yeah which is why we can make fun
of it it's like really
yeah um all right let's move on to our
next bonkers title uh this obviously
is the bonkers one armageddon right the
space nuke
which glows uh bluish green apparently
right
like all nukes really a bluish green
nuke i mean
look with this with a lot of sci-fi
space nukes it's
you know you can argue how ridiculous
they are it really is just
silly because everything in that movie
is silly and there's no way
you don't need it to be a nuke in the
movie it's just oh we just wanted to put
a nuke in there
because that's how michael bay decided
it just raises the stakes or something
just makes it cooler
there's that one scene where the um nasa
engineer scientist was talking about if
you close your fist around a firecracker
then
if it blows up your fist it'll blow up
asteroid the size of texas i guess
and the problem is they kind of have
this goofy adr at the um
third act of the movie where they talk
about all the chunks the asteroid
are blown out of earth's range you know
so
not even pieces of it hit earth the two
halves are going to miss us by 400 miles
and most of the small particles have
been vaporized
it definitely would have vaporized that
shuttle as it was oh yeah for sure
it would uh yeah earth would have not i
feel like earth wouldn't have survived
that i don't know
yeah that's a huge i mean you could have
a asteroid the size of like a football
field and it would cause an extinction
level event yeah that's uh that's every
time i look up at the sky i'm just like
you know what one of these days it could
happen it could
happen anytime you know just live every
day like it's your last remember that
kids why why they make them so morbid
anyway moving on it's a morbid episode
and uh we should say scientists did dig
into it i love it when scientists look
into movies or when mythbusters goes all
into it it's like yeah yeah let's
actually think about this
um and physics students at the
university of leicester concluded that
bruce willis would have needed
a nuke two billion times stronger than
the one used in the film to blow up the
asteroid the size of texas
wow two billion places this in the
bunkers
wow i feel bad for the the nuke that
they did have because it was just wasn't
good enough
not yet it's strong enough you know yeah
it's going to have um
some kind of um self-confidence issues
spring's the story sponsor blue chew
just kidding
we also got to throw an independence day
in this
featured two nukes my friends they tried
to nuke the alien ship over houston
and it just wiped out the city of
houston uh but didn't do any damage to
the uh alien ship
naked
and then at the end they get the nuke
you know will smith and jeff copeland
they they get the alien fighter into the
mothership
from the inside and it works kind of
plays uh similarly to
the um armageddon nuke where they just
gotta outrun the blast
you can never outrun a blast i don't
care how fast you're going maybe the
speed of light
they're going to light maybe captain
marvel could but like hey most people
nah i don't think so i should say this
does not take away any of our enjoyment
of these movies i love independence day
i
love armageddon dark guy rises all these
movies i love them with my heart we're
just really just talking about the nukes
in these movies so don't say yes
[Laughter]
now we also want to talk about the movie
the crazies that came out in 2010
and it's actually real similar to army
of the dead in that there is kind of
like a zombie-esque
anger virus rage virus that sweeps
through this small town
of ogden marsh iowa pretty great film
and it ends
we're rewarding with you know the
government being like we're just going
to blow up this city and they use a nuke
the problem is there's just kind of like
some implausible you know they're
driving a semi
uh down uh highway and it gets
completely rolled over but
no one dies they don't have their seat
belts on yeah so the explosion itself
looks pretty cool as often these do they
got the good mushroom cloud in there
they got the shockwave
mushroom cloud man that's a staple but
they often miss
things like emp they miss the the
thermonuclear aspect of it where the air
literally catches on fire that you
rarely see because it's
horrifying i wonder if we're ever gonna
get like a really accurate
like just nuking in a scene because that
would just be really graphic
well my friend we have some later on
this list
you hold on okay all right all right
okay but just to shout out a couple more
bonkers ones there's a 96 movie broken
arrow with travolta
where nukes gets stolen they do an
underground detonation and that one's
ridiculous because he
turns off his truck to say hey yeah we
got through the emp pulse
but like that would still disable it
doesn't the thing could still be off
it's gonna fry whatever the electronic
device is it's not
it doesn't have to be on at the moment
you're not outsmarting a nuke there
i feel like i feel like these movies are
giving us a really optimistic look at
what a nuke would
would look like if it actually happened
right he's like he's like
well i mean the emp would be the least
of your worries if you're with oh yeah
yeah so maybe i guess you have a point
there but i think this is all just to
get travolta to shout out
god damn what a rush travolta straight
out
just like oscars everywhere he's got
chills
they're multiplied and uh we'll also
throw in true lies true lies uh
detonated i mean james cameron batman
loves his nukes uh they blew up
one of the florida keys which i mean why
stop at one
i mean blew up the titanic and that's
right right yeah
uh war of the worlds has a moment where
they tried to nuke the alien ship in
independence day that was kind of a
reference to the 1954 war of the worlds
where they threw a new dealing ship and
it was just like unscratched yeah
so these are just kind of crazy it's
just like ways to show escalation
don't really do anything to the plot and
it's just to give you uh uh some
fireworks right
so that's our bonkers category we now
move on to our
realistic category this next ring of
fallout from the blast zone this is just
where
the story is more about the the horrors
of
nuclear war and they're meant to
inspire fear into the hearts as they
should
exactly and so just to run through a few
examples of this we have uh the sum of
all fears this was the
film with ben affleck that was based on
the tom clancy novel
uh where basically jack ryan is he's
trying to track down a stolen nuke
uh but it's a smaller one uh and it's
used as
i believe it's a group of neo-nazis in a
way to
spark a war between russia and the
united states hydra
and they target the super bowl in
baltimore
oh geez so you do get to see a nuke and
this came out right after 9 11. i
remember seeing this in the theater and
everyone was kind of freaked out i think
they delayed the movie a little bit
because people were kind of freaked out
at that time yeah that yeah i would be
very
much uncomfortable be like oh this is
too soon this is way too soon
yeah there's that kind of creepy moment
where like the president is there and he
gets tipped off and they rush
the president out of the stadium and
then there's kind of a weird quiet and
then everyone goes
well let's play some football
he's like well we don't know what that
is but let's just play some football
with it nothing bad's gonna happen
that's gonna be fine nothing to see
here please pitch first the uh explosion
itself we kind of see from a distance
there's like a bright light there's a
shockwave that takes out the helicopter
carrying jack it takes out uh the
hospital
um and uh yeah it's kind of creepy but
really
they kind of miss out on the opportunity
to look into
what would really happen in the
aftermath of those they kind of focus on
the
political fallout and the brinkmanship
that happened afterwards
so it does kind of it was meant by tom
clancy to
scare the [ __ ] out of you know world
leaders to be like this could happen
and you know if it does happen let's
hope that diplomacy prevails
and intelligence is listened to
i think that there's immense value in
movies like these because of what you
just said it's just like
you know people can't fathom the true
devastating nature of a bomb
until like they people like artists like
that show you like this is the
our capabilities this is what happens
when we let hate go out of control
so like let's you know relax with the
nuclear
threats or anything you know and just
like you know go back to regular sticks
and and you know little good old
fisticuffs you know what i mean i'm
about to open a fat can of whoop
ass on you bring it on [ __ ]
the sticks and stones all they do is
break your bones but they don't melt
them and that's the key
exactly exactly your bones will be fine
and not melted if you just don't use
nukes i wish i had no bones
done that ought to show you
now we got to move on to my favorite
title on this list
t2 judgment damage oh god it's the
classic one
it's the scariest one i remember
watching it as a kid and being like
i don't know if i could continue this
movie it messed me up
like uh so all the terminator movies are
in a way about the fear of technology
and a fear of like global annihilation
because i think that's kind of the fate
in all these that like
mankind will destroy itself with nukes
really hijacked by skynet
but t2 shows us this nightmare sequence
yeah where she takes a little nap
and then you know she's on the
playground it's uh
judgement day which in that movie was
august 29th 1997.
we made it just like in real life
[Laughter]
uh and you see the city of los angeles
just get
wiped out this one is the first one i
remember seeing that showed the truth
thermonuclear blast of uh a wave of fire
hitting everything
because you see kids and mothers on this
playground
just being blown into skeletal ash
and it's horrifying it is genuine like
that's that's the first nuclear
explosion i've ever seen
in a movie so after that i was like wow
nukes are awful
like straight up awful and like like you
said because like it was like the kid
and like parent imagery of like of the
playground
it was just like wow i'm a kid and like
i thought i was safe
so like good god for it to hit a
playground is what really unsettled uh
everybody watching this especially um
but that's what you got to do you got to
show
that's what happened but i think it
makes the movie
so much better because it really gives
so much stakes to what sarah connor's
paranoia and her theory is it makes her
less crazy in that moment
because we all connect with their fears
so viscerally in that moment
uh and it's it looks so cool because
like
james cameron that guy is insane about
his research he consulted with a ton of
people about what this would actually
look like
and looked at a lot of like test imagery
of when like these towns were blown up
and like he basically used a lot of
model work a lot of great effects in
this to
make it look as realistic as possible
that's some bummer research man
and so when you see their flesh getting
burned off that is what it would look
like
your skin would catch on fire that is
terrifying
it would happen in a moment i don't
think it would be so drawn out you
wouldn't be screaming as a skeleton it
would happen in like the blink of an
eye how does james cameron's wife feel
like he's coming home from work with all
this like research he's like i can't
talk to you honey i gotta think about
uh how uh nuclear blast would uh affect
the human body oh you mean james
cameron's wife at that time catherine
bigelow maybe a little busy making point
break an amazing movie no nukes but a
great movie
uh earlier they were they were a busy
couple in the early 90s that brings us
to
what many people might consider the most
haunting title here it's called the day
after this
in 1983 it was a made for tv movie on
abc
that was really uh a production quality
of what a movie would be at that time
and it had
massive views this was a hundred million
people watched the program during the
initial
broadcast and it scared the
crap out of people uh because this was
that many would say the second height of
the cold war so you had to keep the
missile crisis in the 60s that's where
like oh boy we got real close
uh and then things kind of settled a bit
down in the 70s but then when reagan got
in there
that guy was nuts at first he was like
let's do it he brought in sdi that's
what was nicknamed star wars where he's
like
we're gonna have satellites that shoot
down the nukes from the sky
and then we'll be able to nukes uh
stalingrad
who took my jelly beans nancy where am i
really
good
had a melted brain for the last year of
the presidency
and it was terrifying also i'm not a big
reagan fan not gonna get
too political i'm just saying the guy's
freaking overrated and
uh many of the problems we have with our
country are thanks to him including
uh the collapse of our you know mental
health social safety net thanks reagan
um but thanks anywho
uh but to give reagan some credit here
he actually watched this movie
and it freaked him out too and he made
all the joint chiefs watch it as well
and a lot of people say this movie
had a profound effect on his uh his
rhetoric his tone about um nuclear
brinkmanship
bro that is so cool i love that
but uh just to give you guys a sense of
what this is it literally is about the
day after a hypothetical nuclear strike
following some families in kansas and
missouri and
uh it's because nukes have hit all the
populated areas and it just follows the
day after
where literally like nuclear fallout is
raining down on them
uh and you get these horrifying montages
of crowds running through cities
as panic as they know the nukes are
coming down you see these
uh the emp blast uh shutting down their
cars
and then people get kind of wiped out
this flash of red light exposing their
skeletons
uh it's it's pretty
pretty sickening i can't believe we made
these types of weapons man that's
so awful yeah that's so awful it was so
depressing for a lot of people that uh
abc
and local tv affiliates opened 1-800
hotlines with counselors standing by
during the broadcast oh my god
bro honestly i probably would have been
freaking out too because the cold war
was no joke like that is
anxiety city like releasing a movie like
that
during that time like that is going to
like increase anxiety
times a zillion but it's a good thing to
to see because of like those effects
that um you talked about earlier yeah
uh and if you ever watch the americans
on fx they do a whole episode on it how
they watch it on tv
and then that kind of freaks out you
know elizabeth
as well like the kids are all depressed
by it it's it was a big deal in the 80s
and
another big cautionary tale but one with
a more lighter tone is stanley kubrick's
dr strangelove a
great film uh you have to watch it if
you haven't seen it or
how i learned to stop worrying and
love the bomb it's just probably the
funniest movie
about mutually assured destruction for
sure it's a satire of the way
political leaders bicker and try to
alpha each other out
and just refuse to listen to logic
gentlemen you can't fight in here this
is the war room and the
time was a hobby of theirs yeah so ready
to drop the bomb
until it we eventually get that famous
shot of major kong writing the bomb down
to its target
like it's a wild stallion it ends with
this insane montage
of nukes going off everywhere too we'll
meet again don't know where
don't know when creepy is
terrified but it's it's the closest
you'll get to laughter during
this type of thing uh but it did make a
lot of people think the way
the day after did but this has been
depressing we got to move on to
our biggest category of what have we
done
[Music]
we're ending here because this i think
is the most effective use of nukes
in cinema if you're just trying to
entertain um
while still get people to think about it
because you're able to
explore the implications in the sci-fi
or horror way but it still makes you
think about the nukes
uh a little bit yeah you gotta think
about the nukes man you can't forget
about them and you don't have to go home
and lose sleep over it and you know have
to go talk to an
abc 1 800 hotline therapist about it
stop it get some help i wish i had an
abc
on 800 number for uh just regular life
you know whenever i'm feeling lonely
yeah hey abc you just called whoopee
call whoopi on the view this
oh my god of course what of course that
should be my number one choice
whoopi goldberg the best you'll hear her
snappy that megan mccain
talking to mt those are the only clips
of the view i ever seen
this is megan mccabe saying something
crazy and we'll be just like settle down
we gotta go to commercial
hang on gotta go now uh the first two of
this category we're gonna bring up are
just kind of like you know ones that we
normally talk about new rock stars of
course the avengers where tony stark
throws the nuke at the chitauri fleet
and pisses off thanos and
we group this in this category because
really if you think about it
that was the moment that kind of kicked
off the infinity saga it's what got
thanos attention that moment in infinity
war where thanos said that he knew who
tony stark was
and they both they're both kind of
futuristic they had that moment
right he knew who the iron man was
because that's the guy who threw a nuke
at his fleet through the
wormhole to earth so that's what put
earth and the avengers
on thanos [ __ ] list so it really kind of
started
this whole wave of dread and doom
for the avengers that one use of a
nuclear warhead i mean
tony stark didn't fire it you know the
american military fired it trying to
just
wipe out new york in that way but um but
tony threw it up now
it kind of looks like any space nuke
does whether it's
it's a big flash of light sure sure and
uh you could say that
tony it's plausible that he escapes
because he falls through a wormhole and
then that wormhole closes so
whatever happened on the other side of
the space you just have to worry about i
really like that that um
that that imagery in the movie with like
with tony stark
having to be the one to send the nuke
away because he spent his entire life
making weapons and then nukes like that
so i'm just like yeah this is really
great it's like i have to send this one
outside to defend the people it's just
100 percent yeah and
you see an iron man 3 like even though
the nuke didn't go off like tony was
really messed
up about the events of new york and like
seeing a new go off in front of his face
like i'm sure he's never really seen
that so like
well as he fell through the whole it's
like wow i'm probably gonna get a [ __ ]
ton of radiation right now
yeah it probably freaked them out now uh
similarly there's the
uh nuke in the wolverine that's a single
2013 movie
a pretty cool scene yeah it's kind of
like historical fiction because it shows
a world war ii era wolverine and a pow
camp
and uh you kind of see the the atomic
bomb dropped over the city of nagasaki
which destroyed the town with a 22
kiloton blast
and you see it play out from logan's
perspective as a pow
as he just waits for the explosion to
get over with but then he ends up saving
the officer by covering him with a large
piece of metal to shield him from the
fire
he wins while wolverine just gets his
body burnt
up and that ends up fitting in this
category as well because it sets up the
whole story that takes place decades
later
where wolverine catches up with that guy
and ends up setting up everything in
that plot it's kind of the
the start of the movie and it reminds
you of the horror of that moment
while not dwelling on it too much some
would say this isn't the kind of genre
where you want to dwell on it too much
you know
yeah not to say we should never think
about that yes think about it all the
time think about how horrible this is
uh but in this moment it just kind of
uses it enough to show
that fear while moving beyond it and
showing how
it created and forged this relationship
that ends up having huge narrative
implications later in the movie oh yeah
for sure like
and whenever i think about like nuclear
strikes in my brain like
it's it's the terminator scene and it's
that scene from the wolverine
like it's just seeing him like just burn
up it's just
oh it's such a screaming as it
regenerates yeah yeah yeah
but the best of this uh in this genre
is the godzilla franchise um we saw it
you know in the more recent franchise
that warner's done from 2014 onward but
back to the touhou films of the 50s
because the original inspiration for the
character of godzilla was the united
states
dropping atomic weapons city destroying
weapons
and so basically they conceived this in
the form of this giant kaiju
and throughout that franchise a godzilla
starts off as a villain but ends up
being kind of a neutral a chaotic
neutral
uh and then each of the different kaiju
represents we believe
threats from different countries so
mothra represents
uh japan and it's kind of a gentle giant
you know
you have rodan uh which is kind of a
threat from the soviet union
king ghidorah was supposed to be a
threat from china
uh so you kind of have these different
things that are all these like different
nuclear threats that like
japan viewed as a threat and they kind
of made this giant
metaphor out of it but it ended up
creating this beloved franchise
that struck at the fear of viewers for
just being afraid of being flattened in
your city and there's nowhere to run
or to hide wait tell me how time i talk
you're telling me that godzilla wasn't
inspired by reptile from the rugrats
impossible impossible i don't believe it
[Music]
one of the best things about the later
franchise is the 2014
reboot onward has definitely linked back
to that whole history
uh the opening credits of the 2014 film
show godzilla being lured to bikini
atoll in 1954
where you know nuclear testing went on
in the pacific ocean
and created where spongebob lives um i
know i was thinking
that too i love that that was like
bikini what
yeah yeah so that's like the best
example i think of like
using the fear of nuclear blasts of
nukes and building something out of it
that still continues that cautionary
tale
and we've seen this in a couple other
franchises like obviously planet of the
apes kind of suggested that by the end
of that film
they didn't say it was nukes per se but
he did say you blew it up
damn you damn you all the hell which
what else would blow up the earth to
that degree
um and we didn't see the newt go off we
just saw the statue of liberty and the
implication was that nukes terraform the
earth
and then the hills have eyes is another
one that was kind of
basically suggesting there was new
mexico nuclear testing created
uh these mutants from all the locals who
were irradiated and basically mutated
their bodies and made them into these
horrifying
monsters uh so that was kind of a fear
of not necessarily the blast itself but
the fallout
and then another one i like to mention
is battlestar galactica
specifically 2004 series because that
opens with like the cylons decimating
the planet
with these thermonuclear blasts um and
then you see
the aftermath of it you see this
struggling group of human survivors just
trying to rebuild after that
and survive the cylon annihilation uh so
it's kind of like a
showing terminator but the aftermath of
it oh my i totally forgot that
battlestar galactica opened like that
because you're totally right i love
battlestar galactica
anybody who hasn't seen battle galactica
watch that show it's phenomenal
so say we all yeah it's fantastic
um a lot of a lot of nexium cult members
in that cast but if you could look past
that
oh god really there's at least two
wow jesus christ pretty much everything
you watch in hollywood some member of
the caster crew
is connected to some kind of problematic
cult uh any if you like mad men west
wing or handmaid's tale
elizabeth moss is a scientologist uh oh
yo freaking smallville bro
that [ __ ] really that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
i can't even believe she did that [ __ ]
why didn't you tell me about this we all
keep secrets
all right so knowing all three of these
categories
let's talk about where would army of the
dead fit into
part of me wants to say what have we
done but realistically i think it might
just be bonkers
in that movie what do you think i mean
yeah i would go with bonkers
because it definitely goes with that uh
with that vibe yeah fun to look at
cool mushroom cloud doesn't really make
any sense there's no way vanderhoe at
the end of that movie would have been
able to walk through that nuclear
fallout
or he had a zombie bite he survived for
like
13 14 hours with a zombie bite and
didn't turn right
okay so bonkers it is but before we
continue with our bite size
questions we have to tell you guys a
word from the beautiful people
that make big question possible starting
with upstart paying off debt
can feel like an uphill battle i mean
high interest rates can keep you in an
endless cycle of debt but upstart
can help you get ahead i mean upstart is
a fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debts or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment unlike other
lenders upstart looks at more than just
your credit score like your income
and employment history with this means
that they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners with a five-minute
online rate check you can see their rate
up front for loans between 1000 to 50
000 you can receive funds as fast as one
business day
after accepting your loan find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
big question that's upstart.com big
question and don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
on your loan application go to
upstart.com
big question we also want to thank
perfect foods for sponsoring this
episode every year billions of pounds of
food go
to waste because it doesn't live up to
the strict cosmetic standards of grocery
stores while imperfect foods is on a
mission to reimagine grocery delivery
for a kinder less wasteful world they
deliver sustainable affordable groceries
including produce quality protein and
pantry staples straight to your door
all you have to do is sign up create
your flexible personalized grocery plan
and then shop online each week and get
affordable and sustainable groceries
delivered directly to your door
with imperfect foods grocery shopping
fits seamlessly into your life and every
week is a tasty adventure
sign up with imperfect foods today to
save time save money and save food from
going to waste and right now imperfect
foods is offering our listeners 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and use the promo code big question try
in perfect foods now
for a limited time get 20 off plus free
shipping on your first order
go to perfectfoods.com and use the code
big question to sign up the twenty
percent off plus free shipping and
perfectboost.com
offer code big question all right uh it
looks like we have some bite-sized
questions here
so the first one comes from flash t-man
on discord
uh saying what is groot's lineage
amongst the tree people
okay that's a great question flash t man
from another team man here's your answer
and we're t brothers now
i don't know what i'm saying anyway our
beloved groot is a flora colossus of
from the planet
x where the rest of the tree people come
from and the character of root was
actually introduced to the marvel family
way back in like 1960 in the comic tales
to astonish number 13
created by jack kirby and steve ditko
now back then he was a giant tree
monster attacking earth
absorbing all the objects made of wood
to increase his power
and strength he would make some
occasional appearances here and there
over the years
as a generic villain monster type thing
but it wasn't until 2007 that groot's
story
was retconned and he became the three
word speaking hero that we know
and love today um i believe that was in
the annihilation
series conquest series our modern group
is the descendant of an ancient sapline
of flora colossus in fact
all the floral colossus from planet x
are named groot due to their rigid
wooden physiology their larynx is not
flexible enough to have a robust
vocabulary and because of these stiff
vocal cords when they speak it just
sounds like
i am groot to our untrained human ears
because we're just we we all got classy
years like that yeah our ears
suck zero out of ten years on planet x
the groots are a part of a hive mind of
the forest and given
photonic knowledge by the sage arbor
masters who lead
the branch worlds the roots do have
their own unique traits and
personalities
and ours is a particularly fond of the
sentient mammals on planet x
that aid and assist the groups when he
sees other groups tormenting one of
these creatures he becomes enraged and
attacks his brethren
which causes him to be exiled from
planet x so it's really sad
yeah it's out of a kindness of his heart
he's a good boy
this leads to group becoming captured by
the cree and eventually joining the
guardians of the galaxy when he is
rescued by star-lord and the crew in
2007 and in 2013 we learned that bruges
also goes by the name
his divine and majesty king grew to the
23rd monarch of planet x
custodian does the branch worlds ruler
of all the shades i like that name
you know it's very uh very complicated
name i do like brood better i gotta say
well and based on how he talks to people
he is kind of the ruler of all the
shades
[Laughter]
he's very shady yes but this would
confirm that groot is of
royal lineage and also means that he was
gifted extremely genius level knowledge
by the arbor masters i remember reading
um a comic series from like
a long time ago where root is talking to
maximus the mad
and maximus is like did you guys know
that this guy's actually a genius
[Laughter]
groot is actually very smart uh but he
just says it's very
it's hilarious so whether or not groot
is really of a royal sap line or that is
just a story he made up
to sound impressive we may never know
but he certainly did inherit some
killer dance moves yeah he did what a
great answer thank you mt oh
one other question uh why was bruce
wayne
raised by alfred instead of another
wayne family member that's a great
question that's a really great question
and answer that the concept of the
orphan bruce wayne being raised by
his butler after the death of his
parents is actually a modern retcon of
batman's history
alfred pennyworth wasn't introduced into
the batman comics until well after like
robin catwoman the joker and a host of
like other villains of the rogues
gallery
had already interacted with the caped
crusader and alfred was introduced in
batman number 16
in 1943 and he was originally unaware of
bruce wayne's alter ego
alfred is the son of jarvis a previous
butler of the wayne family which is you
know
apparently a very famous butler name is
very popular okay
marvel oh okay i see what you did there
who arrives in gotham city from
england to fulfill his father's dying
wish that he follow the family tradition
and become
the wayne family bubble i don't know why
the dreams are so small here but
be a servant
you will be the servant for the rest of
your life please
it's like that i will dad okay dad
wow that is uh that's pretty sad but hey
alfred
he's literally the best butler out of
all of them so i'm glad he did it the
idea that alfred raised an orphan bruce
wayne started with the animated show
super friends in 1985 on an episode
called
the fear it was eventually merged into
comic book canon
now this factoid was then cemented with
the 1989
tim burton batman film along with
christopher nolan's batman begins
and the recent show gotham so alfred
ain't going anywhere he's here to stay
it's like this is just
this is just the canon now and as for
extended family taking in bruce
he didn't really have any like bruce was
the last of the wanes and that's what
makes it really significant with
the wayne's death um unless you account
for the immortal thomas wayne from the
18th century
aka dr hurt but i don't think he'd be a
really good father figure so we're not
gonna really go into that yeah
but jacob kane was introduced in 2011 as
martha wayne's brother
and bruce's uncle and jacob kane is the
father of kate and elizabeth kane
bruce's cousins of course and kate kane
goes on to become that woman of course
and fight side by side
with batman okay so that was just kind
of released late and at that point
you had already understood that alfred
was part of the mythology
that makes sense there you go thanks mt
now it is time for
my favorite part of the show it's the
box of scraps
alex
and today's box of scraps question for
you eric is
what secret has been the most difficult
for you to keep
in your lifetime oh my god um
i'm not very good at keeping secrets um
i just kind of you know people can
always see
in my face if i'm hiding something from
them i don't have a very good poker face
and uh i remember when i was a kid i was
really bad at it and
people just wouldn't tell me the
surprise because i would ruin it
and how rude yeah i remember four uh so
my sister
lucy went into the peace corps to
turkmenistan and
uh we're all you know we all missed her
a whole lot because we didn't get a lot
of contact with this the first time
anyone in the family had moved away
across the world um
and my mom had her 50th birthday party
and my dad wanted to have this big
surprise party and invite everyone over
and uh we were going to get home or he
was going to bring her home after lunch
and then everyone was going to beat her
in the house
um but he found a way to get my sister
to come home from turkmenistan just as a
visit
um and uh it was such a big deal because
there was a lot of moving parts it's
hard to
get someone to travel across the world
like that from a country like that
um yeah but uh they were able to do it
and like
i it was so hard for me to keep that see
there's so many times i will spoil that
i think at one point i even said like i
can't wait to see lucy
uh and like my sister's like mom's like
what'd you say and i said
oh i meant to say and i said some like
other sister i just lied and
she's like okay and like i was just so
freaked my long lost sister that i
haven't seen
her she's my favorite ps character my
mom's like i guess
lucy fetish uh or like the scarlett
johansson movie that didn't exist yet
i can't wait to see that um but no
uh so the day of the party i was really
nervous
um like i was gonna say something i was
gonna say something
uh and then even when the party happened
everyone said surprise saying happy
birthday to my mom
and at the very end of the song my
sister was gonna run around the side of
the house
uh and sneak up on my mom put her hands
around her eyes
and say guess who and that's how my mom
was gonna see and then
was gonna lose it um and i almost i was
so worried i was gonna say it out loud
to do something
to uh to trigger it and then uh so right
as the song ended i was like oh
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say it i'm gonna
say it and then our
priest who we invited the party goes
hey nancy hey nancy
look who's here he had to be that guy
and then my sister lucy was like okay
and then she ran up it's like hi mom and
then the priest ruined the surprise so i
was clear i didn't ruin it
god damn it priests all of us were like
why did father tony do that
why did you have to make it about him
anyway goddammit father tell
why why just kidding that's that's a
nice guy
he's a nice jovial guy he just said hey
he wanted to be part of that
but at the end of the day you didn't
spoil the secret and yeah he saved me so
that's why
he jumped on the grenade for me so i
always think
maybe he knew that you were about to pop
he's like you know what i need to save
this boy
yeah uh how about umc what's the hardest
secret that you've ever had to keep
i would have to say it was my little
brother's
engagement because um he like my when my
little brother does something he goes
like over the top
and so like when he set up this whole
thing we're like
um he he pretended like so my little
brother's
fiance at the time anyway was uh he's a
photographer and so she's like
hey i have this job for you so he sent
her like on like this
random fake job just taking pictures
while like everybody that both of us
knew like met up at this final
location where she was supposed to shoot
and so um like it was just like this
really
great elaborate plan and i knew it for
weeks and so like whenever i would see
uh his fiancee be like hey what's going
on
and like i love a good surprise and like
i love like you know i just love love in
general so i'm just like you don't know
a really great thing's about to happen
and like i just i don't know i just part
of me just like i really want to say it
like
i don't want to i would never spoil an
engagement but like it's just like
wow like this i know you're going to be
really happy so i just really want to
tell you now so i can experience your
happiness but it's you know i'm not that
selfish as a person
um but anyway that was i guess that's
the only real reason for me
yeah at the end of the day
i did no right before he was about to do
it i'm like ha ha ha wait a minute
joe asked me to say guess what hey
look who's here look who's here
it's my little brother um anyway it's
you know it's it's hard to keep a secret
sometimes but for the most part i think
i do a pretty good job yeah
i think um you've kept my secret from
all the rockstars viewers
oh yes that you're secretly hannah
montana
[Music]
oh my god if you were secretly miley
cyrus everything i knew about
the world would be a question
you know what you're giving me more and
more evidence that you might be
ahead about it slash my mind just take
off my clothes and swing around my
wrecking balls oh my god please just
kidding
i got my fitness origins bod it's going
to last now
hey you're not looking good man i feel
like every time i see you you look more
and more healthier like you're just like
dang
yeah but i feel like you're like you
look stronger yeah i don't know
weaker on the inside that's where it
counts
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank eric for
joining me this episode you can follow
him at eavos
on twitter wherever he's at follow me at
mastertainment wherever i'm at
but most importantly please follow new
rockstars send us your big questions
using the hashtag bigquestion subscribe
to the podcast feed give us a nice
rating and review because that really
helped us a lot
and subscribe to rockstars here on
youtube and hit that notification bell
so you get notifications whenever we
upload
dope [ __ ] anyways thank you guys for
watching
stay safe and we love you guys yeah bye
[Music]
you